uh
this pocket
the movement is
not here
back in this pocket
[Music]
move behind his elbow if his
elbow's uh out here
and you see him get to the center on the
movement
and that's going to require strength
so your goal is to move
behind behind his elbow wherever his
elbow is
you're behind it
[Music]
there's not enough space for feet apart
there's space for feet together
so think about that get behind his elbow
don't over penetrate that wouldn't be
good
behind his hips telling you where to
stop
too far behind
oh
don't push anything
okay let's try
here
this is like two inches off and you're
gonna
pull them too now you have it but those
two inches
is not marshall you're not gonna do that
against someone stronger
it's not gonna happen you're not gonna
get it
so that's why
[Music]
this is going to be wrong it's not not
not going to be
marshally successful
move into space
you turned here you turned your phone
how to get there that's where to get
there how to get there
you have to use your ground pop so
you're going to shift your weight
into the yarn phase so that it could
drive
not here double pivot
on double
shift weight into yawn
drive boom
shift weight into yawn into the turn
step
yawn drive
yawn turn
yawn enter
yawn turn other foot down
that means knees to toe
drive knees to toe
turn bring the foot in the foot
on the hip not like this
knees to toe step
knees to toe turn bring the other foot
in
knees to toe drive
knees to toe turn
knees to toe step
knees to toe knees to toe
turn so uh
he's pushing them push push
okay strong if i double pivot i can't
get going
knees to toe you can walk
so not like this
strong strong
[Music]
even though i'm not pushing on him
strong movement
all right
oh
shift weight knees to toe
drive
and he's bracing him and so i'm going to
shift
and then i can move
i want to engage my legs
shift then that drop
engage the leg knee to toe young face
positive so if you double pivot
you're not gonna get it knees to toe
drive okay let's go and breathe
okay so in terms of weight
left foot right foot
i'll be on the left foot you're going to
want a moment of the left foot
okay so if he if he comes into me and
i'm on the right foot it's
a little harder to ground vector if he
comes into me and on the left foot i can
do it
okay you have to account for that
that when you're here he's going he
might come this way
that's very much like when you go uh
coke you pull
right right foot
young phase rotate the left foot is
doing the ground vectoring
the left foot so not the right foot
not both feet not both feet
here so he pushes it goes into the
ground
on the left foot the outside foot
it's just a moment of surety
so right weight
boom left weight
boom get that left foot
the outside foot the right foot in this
case
active so he can't come into you
waiting wait here
wait now on the other foot
weight on the outside foot
[Music]
wait wait wait
mid foot vector like dead lifting mid
foot vector
oh release the lower legs
he has to come he has to come towards me
if he's going away from me
that cd me
so if i
have to pull him
that can't be right
i wouldn't have to pull something that's
coming to me
that just has to be taken off the table
you can have it where your uke tries to
counter
this position so maybe they're coming at
me
you see and he has his technique right
here
or maybe he tries to reinforce his elbow
with his leg i can't go down
that's going to create an opening for
ora
you can also do it in kihon
when you lower the elbow his weight
starts to fall this way
because his leg swings out so his head
comes to me
okay oh when you start to lower the
elbow
you're gonna see he comes this way and
it replicates
the ura opening okay
down not in down
so for me beginner is i don't give them
the counter ability because they'll add
energy to the technique
and they'll fall harder okay so beginner
ura manifestation as it goes down
and you're gonna feel the energy go that
way okay
here it comes okay that's the energy i
pledge
with boom
down there i turn
so when i when i go down and he starts
to
come here it's it is getting closer the
radius will get closer
so that that energy gets taken around
me i don't let it get closer
energy is coming at me and i take it in
front
see
in front and i just keep turning to keep
it
for beginner level okay down
you'll feel it
okay so that initial down
is going to be on the output but once i
bring it this way
it's going to be on the in foot weight
which foot is weighted which foot is the
ground back
down oh yeah and then
out past me and i stay on the in foot
wait
down around
there you go down
and just aiming this energy that's
coming out the energy's coming this way
you see it
and just keep it going forward and i
keep staying inside of it
i'm not doing a lot of strength not a
lot of strength
i'm not taking him down energy's coming
at me
and i just let it go around me and i
stay inside
so
[Music]
right
he said his his energy is coming
this way and that justifies gordon
energy coming towards me turn energy
coming towards me turn
okay so energy's coming towards me
i don't want to put it under me
that that didn't stop the clash
has to go around me
this is a redirection his energy's
coming towards me
redirected
i'm not trying to push it down i
redirect his energy that
doesn't change whether you hold the
wrist the wrist is not part of the
technique
the elbow's where i redirect his energy
[Music]
so all i did was a redirection
i didn't i didn't force him down
i didn't pull him down i redirected
his centripetal energy i redirected
and i'm just staying with it without
letting it get
underneath me i keep it going out
when you start picking it up you'll see
he gets pretty low with just the
redirection
it doesn't have to go underneath
so
okay okay so let's look at uh
what happens it usually ends up about
there
with the redirection
[Music]
usually some case go ahead and dive
down okay
but you know you see
he seems close to the ground and you're
going to want to go
but people are strong and that's not the
art
so the same redirection that you did
with his centripetal
energy you're going to do
with his lifting energy so
i get a gun around here and you'll feel
oh there's there's his strength instead
of putting it
under you and pushing more there's his
strength
it keeps going out you see
so this inward energy goes out
this upward energy goes out
okay
inward energy out
upward energy out
we'll go back to no wrist there it is
right there
out up out
redirect energy around me
and no out
that resistance
i'm not leading with this hand like you
see a lot of people saying it's not
it's on the elbow it's on the elbow
around no
around again so the wrist hand
is just for the ride it's just holding
on to the right it just
it doesn't do anything just for the ride
my stance also doesn't do anything
my stance is just to keep my uh
proper body mechanic so that i reach his
arm
if i stay here you see he gapped me
so i moved my stance to stay up with the
following elbow
that is being led out
[Music]
my weight dropping is not a
gravitational
energy it's an adhesion maintenance
[Music]
hey
so that would be the mechanical
architecture but there is a side
though i'm working with energy
redirection obviously
okay there is an internal aspect which
makes it
all function okay
so uh the first one we already did
i can actually move a great deal of mass
um that he could brace him
okay i because i'm moving in a ground
vector
i can move a great deal of mass
even though in the technique without my
weight i don't use that mass
i don't use that force capacity to get
here
i go through yin space to get there but
that
integrity is what allows
the centrifugal energy to be
to capitalize upon his centripetal
energy
if i'm a gooey axis
then i can't take centripetal energy
and transfer it into centrifugal energy
my
axis starts to move you see
it moves not only in space but moves
in different configurations it loses
integrity and so energy cannot be
redirected
and i have to go to external shut them
down
okay the other
um the next key internal aspect
is the ikea adhesion
here so i'm not grabbing him
and not grabbing his energy coming
inward inward i need
energy going outward okay
now when you don't have an ik adhesion
it's going to make your thumb
crucial to the energy transfer
but that's a very weak thing
you see which is why most people go
it
and they get over the top and they try
to shove the guy down
but uh your adhesion just stands up
so my adhesion is this skill
okay this skill
not this skill so
you're you where wherever you adhere
whatever you adhere
you're moving it you're moving it okay
and the same goes on this hand so
it's it's an adhesion that keeps that
hand from sliding
okay which makes me not have to grab it
i don't have to grab i already have
control
so he's in this ik adhesion and this
ik adhesion and even if he's static
right he's going to move even if he
pulls he's pulling out it just makes the
adhesion
uh stickier okay and if you don't have
that
you're going to have to rely on pulling
and then pulling doesn't work okay it
works in choreography okay
the second one is or the third one
uh when he hits the ground
on the energy comes up that is
projected out
yes it is guided it is redirected but
it's redirected with the projection
okay so saying he grab he grabbed
is redirected with the projection
okay so as i feel that
resistance right there he
hits that ground vector
coq projection moment that's what sends
him
out okay that is why the technique looks
instead of okay because he gave an
extra resistance and i internally
received it and then internally
projected it out okay so
as he's coming around that's what that
is
okay
and i carry it every time i feel this
energy the ground vectors boom
that's why it goes
different would be this
i don't need the ground vector in that
technique but i sure needed a lot of
weight and strength okay
so here i'm dropping with it there's no
way i'm projecting that
there's no way i'm projecting it
you're going to pay attention
i stayed out until he projected
boom there it is that's when i load
i don't lower the lower hand i project
to lower him
and i lower to stay with him
different
projections
gravity
okay
without those three
repetitions of the internal aspects the
technique
often has to change
not for the better
[Music]
you